[Music]
jack
yes
how you doing man i think it's time to
revisit
the electric car
phenomenal yes i think it's time for the
whole world to visit the electric car
the whole world the whole world the
entire world the whole world is watching
so let's let's remember a few things all
right back when electricity
was discovered and harnessed and
there were some early ideas about
electric cars but they they didn't catch
on relative to the combustion engine
and there was some politics there's some
you know this sort of thing right so
exxon was invented
excellent you know once they embed a x
on it was just like death to you
electric no it was just
so
so the point is right now electric
vehicles are making a comeback the the
stigma that electric vehicles had for so
long was that they were underpowered or
they looked ugly or no no one's getting
a date if you're picking somebody up in
exactly an electric vehicle and so
uh so that that stereotype has been
broken and busted open and so now you
have many manufacturers who are
who are
putting forth
their
sexy
electrical electric cars and so so
there's still some challenges for
example they still run on batteries
right now battery it's like okay that
was invented in the you know 19th
century
the chemistry was a little different
but if you want to look at sort of the
last holdout
of a century-old technology within a
modern vehicle it's the battery
battery technology never thought of it
that way but you're absolutely right it
is and it is
really kind of an antiquated way of
looking about thinking about powering
things correct and but it's nonetheless
a a an affected means of storing energy
right an effective means of storing
energy that you but you have to recharge
it but you carry that around with you
okay here's the problem if you have pure
solar panels on your car okay well what
happens if a cloud goes in front of the
sun okay you could you could picture
this where all these cars are
approaching the intersection and then
like a cloud goes in front of something
they all just stopped oh everybody just
slows down
and then until the cloud goes away and
then they keep going right they weren't
being polite
nobody was being polite
so so there are sources of energy that
are in the moment
that you that are not effective for cars
because you want to be able to store it
and use it on command this is what made
gasoline so oil derived products so
effective because they have a lot of
chemical energy built into their
molecules you carry that with you you
load up over here you carry it with you
you use it up and then you reload at
another destination so the portability
of energy is everything
all right
so chuck it all comes down to
portability of your source of energy
okay that's what it is it comes down to
that okay so
here's an interesting fact
all right
most of our transportation industry runs
on gasoline or diesel okay right
and so we all know where to get that you
get that at a gas station
and we all know where the oil comes from
it's from the middle east or from an
alaska pipeline or from
venezuela wherever
and wherever there's trouble in the
world
if there's trouble in the world you know
we got some oil there you know we got
some oil there
you know what i mean anybody dropping
bombs got to be some oil
so
there's
so the
so
oil
is
geopolitically significant
absolutely yeah because not everybody in
the world has their own oil well where
they just draw their own energy from
earth's crust right okay so somebody's
gonna have it and they're gonna have
more of it than you do now you have to
negotiate for it buy it and are they
your friend are they your enemy or are
they your frenemy all right so all of
this matters so that you can drive your
car to work each morning so the point is
the geopolitics of access to oil
influences things like your price of gas
at the pump right and
so that's weird when you think about it
so
so what happens when you use an electric
car
and yes you do have this 100 year old
technology the battery but it's all we
have for now and the batteries are
getting better than they were but
they're still batteries but fine all
right i've got a battery
and that and i use it all up and i have
to charge it right so what is the
battery there's like all these electrons
in one half of the battery
and they have energy there and by
tapping that energy the electrons move
to the other side of the battery and
then your battery's dead
okay
in a non-rechargeable battery you then
throw it away in a rechargeable battery
you reverse the current and the
electrons move upstream thinking like
salmon swimming upstream and they go
upstream and they lodge themselves
on the opposite plate again that's
that's basically a battery but first
they mate with another electron and die
no so that's where the salmon analogy
breaks down i'm sorry okay i'm sorry
and a bear is ready to eat them
just swipes them out of the water
poor salmon be nice uh so
um oh a quick point there a point we've
made before but it's worth saying in
this moment
if you have a freshly dead battery okay
and then you
put in the reverse charge those
electrons can lodge anywhere on that
opposite plate that they happen to land
okay they got a zillion places to go
right okay to choose from and then they
land there but when you're half charged
only half the spaces are left
when you're 90
charged
there's only 10 of the spaces left
gotcha okay
all right so the electrons have a harder
time finding
that remaining spot
it's like musical chairs for electrons
or or a big parking lot around a
football stadium if you're the first one
there park anywhere right that's true
yeah and you could park within seconds
right but if you come later there's a
spot for you but you got to find it
it could take you a hat taking a half
hour to park okay
so
as the charge gets higher and higher on
your battery
the time it takes to charge the rest of
it continues to grow right okay so just
something to keep in mind
so your battery is not screwing with
your people
yeah you know it's not it's not just
like you know breaking down on yet in
the last ten percent which is right
right it's not taking ever it's not
messing with you in the last 10 20
hey guys i thought this would be a
perfect time to take a break from the
explainer and introduce you to the
all-electric chevrolet bolt euv talk
about electric vehicles this is the
everyday electric vehicle for everyday
people which means it's everyday awesome
come on check it out just take a look at
the power flow screen that shows you in
real time how the energy is flowing to
and from the high voltage battery and
don't get me started on how much i never
want to go to the gas station again
imagine being able to charge your car
ahead of time whether it's while you're
at work having dinner i mean come on
sign me up and if that's not enough what
if your electric vehicle could do the
driving for you that's right the chevy
volt euv has a hands-free driving
assistance feature called super cruise
ensuring that your commute will never be
the same again hey thanks to chevrolet
for letting me check out their really
cool euv and right now i have to take a
nice quiet ride see what i did there
now i want to recharge my battery
it's electric
so i plug it into the wall
oh
oh wait a minute
well where does the wall get its energy
from your regional power station right
let's go there so you walk down to the
power and say hi hey folks how are you
making power today
it's nice to see you have such a cordial
relationship
with your electric company
cause if i walk down i'm gonna be like
what the hell is up with this bill
now i ain't even been home for two weeks
i haven't been home for two weeks and
this bill is exactly the same i haven't
run the dishwasher the washing machine
right
what's up people what kind of clip joint
are you running
and chuck i agree i go on vacation come
back and don't make no damn different
no difference okay
so pretending i have a relationship with
the power company manager all right so i
say how you making energy today and they
show me the coal cars that drive up dump
coal into the hopper and they burn the
coal
so that's that that was a fossil fuels
because coal comes from long dead plants
and
this is carbon that had been sequestered
for millions of years that's now getting
released into the atmosphere so chuck
here's the catch with the coal cars that
are dumping coal into the hoppers that
are burning it in the electric company
so
that electric company just inv i'm i'm
making this up but you get a sense of
this that electricity just in vets
invested in solar panels okay they have
a solar panel array out back
all right what else do they have they
have they're tapped into a hydroelectric
plant nice all right it's up the road a
bit okay
um and what else might they have maybe a
little offshore wind or maybe there are
some winds okay some wind farms so
what's happening now is
their energy profile that they generate
can come from any combination of these
sources
if you wanted to run your car off of
wind energy you couldn't or solar you
couldn't or or or hydroelectric you
couldn't but the electric company can
and they can send it to your wall socket
right
so the engine of your car doesn't have
to be able to run off of 12 different
ingredients
it doesn't have your car doesn't have to
be so designed as to be able to have to
have solar panels and wind turbines and
it doesn't have to have any of that it
just has to have a power plug
that plugs into the wall
and then you can put pressure on the
power companies
to generate energies in whatever green
way you dictate or want or desire
excellent and that way your car
ends up being equipped to go forward in
a green turning
society
whereas your your internal combustion
engine car even though they still far
outnumber electric cars and they're
still in many ways cheaper to run and
operate
um the fact is
if you're going to be future proofing
your driving
you'd want to think about this as an
option
right
right but the cool thing is that
electric cars
have
kind of proven
to be
better in many respects i mean oh yeah i
mean so i was just talking about the
basic physics of it but okay yeah first
of all last i checked this forty
thousand forty thousand electric
charging stations across the country
right
forty thousand of them but in addition
if the whole car is electric and and
they're modern and new they're of course
on the internet they you can talk to it
from the internet everything is
connected everything it's like if you
reinvented the car today
it's how you would design a car and
that's how all the great car
manufacturers are putting their cars on
the road right now they're electric cars
so
so i look forward to what that future is
plus an electric car in principle can
talk to another electric car absolutely
think about that so let's say excuse me
i want to change lanes now could you
give me a little space and the cars to
my right
separate and unless unless it's from
boston no
if it's from boston it'd be like ah
screw you
i'm in a wicked hurry
electric cars with with accident with
regional accidents with regional access
you're on i-95 it's like hey hey i'm
driving over here yeah screw you i'm in
a wicked harry
you and your cat
boston meets brooklyn on interstate 95.
[Laughter]
so so anyhow so electric cars is the
future it really is and uh by the way
the chemicals that
manufacture an electric car those are
not all green you know you still got to
make the car so but these are first
steps and i i applaud them all
because it means society is responding
to the
to the the cry of danger that scientists
have been put
have put forth for decades now regarding
the our role in the warming of this
planet literally decades decades and the
catastrophic consequences that would
unfold as a result at one last point
before we
land this plane or park this car
electric cars have many fewer moving
parts right
and every time you have two parts moving
against one another
against each other
there's wear and tear and they create
friction
and friction is the great black hole
of power
of the energy that you put into your car
oh okay i never thought of it that way i
but you're right if you got to get the
you got to get the energies from
somewhere that has to come from
somewhere why do you think your engine
gets hot right right oh because it's
working no it's because there's energy
you wanted to use to go forward right
that it couldn't use that way so it's
heating up the engine it's heating up
the engine wow it's it's it's an
inefficient delivery of power correct
correct it says however efficient it is
it's less efficient than an electric car
which has many fewer moving parts right
and so it doesn't get as hot it does
things can get hot but not from the
friction of the
parts and also of course with fewer
moving parts there's fewer stuff to
break right
i mean think about how many moving parts
are in an internal combustion engine car
oh my gosh
like you know countless thousands of
parts
and so with an electric car fewer parts
uh fewer maintenance lower maintenance
bills or fewer maintenance bills less
frequent and so
so it's got a lot going for it electric
now let's talk about the flux capacitor
nope that has to be a whole other show
oh cause i'm working on one myself and
all right there you go
that's cool man everything you ever
never needed to know almost everything
about
electric cars i can't wait to get one
all right this has been star talk
explainer all about electric vehicles or
some about electric vehicles keep
looking up
[Music]
you